numbers on stephen brawl it's a very
mixed bag for steven because uh
there are long stretches within games
where
he looks like he did that long stretch
of last year
let's see hayes go to work and he got
him wow what a play by key brian hayes
right out of the gates yeah some guys
they just believe the press clips
they're going to see it for themselves
nice accurate throw i mean just
throws strays of string right over the
back now the batter is modesty batting
from the right side
oh oh and let's just do a repeat look at
this
he has suddenly gotten hot and alberto
monteci
has three home runs this week one
nothing royals
watch him here oh see the head stayed
right in place that's what we're talking
about his hands are good fizz
but everything was moving and when it
moves ahead especially
so does the ball we miss it that's
right-handed bell hitting
just 209 still two and two kubich
delivers
this time a fastball that's a ground
single to right field
and moran's headed to third and he is
going to be there
standing up as the throw is cut off and
josh bell
with a base hit through the right side
pirates in business runners at first and
third
great job by chris bubich first and
third nobody out
strikes out the next three salvador just
coming off the
injured list today missed 20 games he
had that left eye
problem but he was working over the
alternate camp and he hits it to the
right side and look at this
fantasy turns second and goes to third
because you just called that
that was awesome that paul's a foot and
a half outside
we know he's a bad ball hitter isn't
that a beautiful thing
reaching out getting hit they've missed
him
[Applause]
first and third and the right man the
right spot the rbi guy
franco with 28. well he bloops it
towards left center field modesty down
the line will score on the blue pit
salvi hustles to second base and
franco looks in at his teammates and he
said that's when you're hot
when you get a swing like that you get
an rbi this has been a sore spot for his
bases loaded this year for the royals
gets away here comes perez
and the royals take a three-nothing lead
on a wild pitch
yeah this misses the mark and not sure
why stallings the catcher tried to
backhand that when it was on his
forehand side
nobody out let's go now we got a chance
to put a run up there maybe two runs of
our own
yeah same scenario first and third
nobody out in the second but
found a way to get out of it with three
strikeouts there's that base head he
asked for
moran can trot him bells on his way to
third he'll be held there
it's a double for stalling look at the
opportunity now to tie the game with
that big hit
one more batter to get out of this jam
here in the fourth and he swings and
it's a fly ball
right center field bubba is over from
center and he's got it so
all things considered it's not a bad
inning for bubic
he gives up just the one run on three
hits and the pirates strand two
alberto monteci at the plate
he's responsible for the first royals
run a home run to
left field back in inning number one
stratton's still out there and he was
throwing
nothing but strikes in the previous
inning to retire
the royals in order off the plate
he walks modestly on to see walking
twice tonight
unheard of truly good inconceivable
well she did strike out at first i
thought it was called ball four
right down the middle but monastery
ripped it off with no trouble
monday goes pitch is taken throw to
third
safe through the whole right side that's
a base hit
bronco comes through and modesty scores
in the royals in front four to one
well that's nice right there good short
swinging 94 that's away so he didn't do
too much at all
and he's been really coming up clutch
bell is coming up
that's right down the line and bell
sends one out of here for a home run
oh jackson like josh knows his fifth
home run
a two-run shot puts the bucks within a
run in the eighth
that was very clutch we needed a big hit
like that i know where the fence hit
greg holla comes out of the bullpen
trying to save this game and hand chris
bubich his first major league win
oh man he struck him out didn't give in
hud
after back to back fastballs on a 3-2
count he goes with the breaker
now gonzalez who is oh for four got him
back-to-back strikeouts by greg holland
to open the top of the night
greg is not gonna beat he beat on his
second best pitch and right now his
second best pitch is that fastball
right side nikki lopez gobbles it up and
throws him out congratulations chris
boobage your first win in your bigly
career you earned it
with four wins in a row now the royals
are feeling great about themselves